So I'm asking people about The Hunger Games
and how they would survive.
and I wanna know what your tactic is for surviving The Hunger Games.
*grumpy meow*
Uhhh wow.
I don't think I would survive.
No, I would die first.
I'd die within an instant.
I would not survive.
I'm not a survivor.
I'd just ask them to kill me immediately.
That's so dark though. You'd ask them to kill you?
I'd be like, "Just end my misery now."
Can I just stay in one place and wait for everyone else to die?
Do you know what weapon you would use?
A knife.
Crossbow,
which is cooler than a regular bow.
My weapon would be friendship.
I would have a bag of donuts with me!
Smuggle that s@#$ in your purse.
What weapon would you use to defend yourself?
I'd get Lasik.
Because you break your glasses, or you lose a contact... like -
you're screwed.
I would say I would hide.
Just hide.
I'm pretty good at hiding.
I'm really good at hiding.
I would take cow manure.
and cake it onto myself.
and then I would hide.
They're all hiding?
F@#$ that S@#$
I'm gonna light flares, and start a bonfire.
And get everybody into one arena.
I'm gonna forge an alliance with you.
And then I'll just heave a harpoon into your back.
And eat your body.
But you know you told me that, so that's not gonna work.
You son of a b@#$&
Do you have a tactic for surviving?
Stick with Jennifer Lawrence she always seems to win that.
I'm wondering how Grumpy Cat would survive on The Hunger Games...
I'm trying to gauge her mood right now.
I think she hates us all equally.